bonjour à tous vous avez déjà la date
dans vos agendas il faut qu'elle soit
maintenant dans tous les agendas cette
date c'est le 29 septembre au premier
octobre pourquoi pour l'université de
rentrée du Mouvement Démocrate où ça a
Guidel en Bretagne c'est un temps fort
pour notre famille politique de se
retrouver tous ensemble pour débattre de
l'avenir de notre pays des grands enjeux
structurants à l'échelle internationale
et donc aussi de parler d'Europe bien
évidemment les élections européennes
sont dans moins de 300 jours c'est
capital pour nous qui sommes
fondamentalement européens de pouvoir de
débattre d'énormément de sujets bien
évidemment la guerre en Ukraine le
changement climatique l'intelligence
artificielle les enjeux sociaux donc
rendez-vous dès le 29 septembre à Guidel